[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Martha is
up next in Orlando Martha welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my call
first of all sure uh I've got a quick
situation I'm getting ready to retire in
the next couple years I'm debt free and
um my question is I don't get a lot I
won't have a lot of income coming in uh
once I reach Tire I am self-employed
like I said not going to get much in in
Social Security so therefore I've got a
couple investment properties who
actually generates income right now so I
was thinking um my personal home the
Homestead Property if it's twice to do a
a reverse mortgage on that take that
money from that and buy another property
cash obviously and use that as income
rent it out and use the money as income
where did you hear hear about this idea
of the reverse
mortgage oh I'm in I'm in real estate oh
okay so you know the ins and outs of
these deals yes oh boy and it still
sounds like a good idea to you yes
because um you know even though my home
Tom celic is selling these schlepping
them on late night
television yes oh boy well I have strong
feelings against reverse mortgages so I
cannot in good faith tell you or anyone
else who would call into the show that
this is a wise decision for their
financial future it puts your home at
risk it's adding more debt to your name
it's causing you to go backwards
financially and the interest in fees can
reduce that Equity even further and if
you don't meet the loan obligations you
know what happens you're in real estate
foreclosure yes yeah but um the real the
home um the reverse mortgage is until
you pass away you can stay there as long
as you can
sure but I'm confused why this is a
money-making scheme to do the reverse
reverse mortgage to get a
rental because I'll get the equity I got
from my home take half of it okay and
put it into another home home paid for
for it huh is the home paid for yes so
you have no payments on the home and
we're going to create a payment they're
going to pay you by robbing your Equity
over time no they're not going to pay me
I'm going to take all the equities on
the house and put put it into so you're
talking about a home equity
loan no no no no you can take the the
funds a lump sum a lumpsum okay and
that's what you would do that's enough
that's GNA give me more than 400 C
500,000 which I can use and purchase an
uh another home and then generate income
that way but that's essential like you
saying hey should I go take out a
mortgage for $500,000 as a retirement
plan yeah but I'm not paying on it how
are you I don't understand how you don't
think this debt is attached to your
name it is attached but I'm not making
payments I need to make income well this
isn't the plan if we're talking about
making income better plan so you have
rentals what are the rental properties
worth um one is worth
400,000 okay and the other
one is 880,000 okay and are they paid
for or do you have mortgages on them
no they're paid for everything's paid
for and what's your current house
worth it's over 900,000 love it and do
you have anything else to your name any
other assets anything in
retirement very little okay so on paper
I'm seeing you have $1.5 million in real
estate or
so so wouldn't this be a better plan if
you're looking at making income why
don't we sell maybe your personal maybe
we sell everything and we figure out a
new living situation ation so that you
can free up that cash and invest that
instead cuz these rental properties what
are they making investing I don't know
how to invest I've got burn in in in all
these Investments and well I want you to
make wise Investments there's a broad
spectrum from sucks to amazing when it
comes to investing but I'm telling you
you don't have to do this rental income
plan what what are they bringing in
total what's the net profit per
month I will say they bring like
2400 okay and that's not enough for you
to live off of on top of Social Security
no okay so how much do you need to live
off of I need at least another I will
say about seven Grand you have $10,000
in expenses with no payments yeah I like
I like to
travel you don't have enough money to
travel that's not a living expense
that's like me saying George asking me
Ken how much you need to live off of and
I throw a huge number out there and I go
well I like to drive I need I told you
no that's not what you need no that's no
George has been very nice I'm going to
be very honest with you need
$7,600 every single month to travel no
first of all no stop you don't need to
travel it need is to pay I know but I'm
I'm irritated listening to all this
Martha we irritated everything is paid
okay I got my car he's getting a little
over but you don't need $10,000 you
don't need 10
grand you need to pay for your utilities
you need to pay for your food you need
to pay for your clothes Transportation
uh other other miscellaneous expenses
you can save up but you don't need that
kind of money and to take out a loan
from your Equity a reverse mortgage to
get another house to spit off a little
bit of money for all of the risk and all
of the upkeep and everything else it's
just nonsensical it doesn't make any
sense I would rather you sell all your
properties and scale back your living
and you're going to have a very nice net
yeah I guess so I guess you're right
yeah I mean you know I mean you can just
less travel for me then that means less
travel less spending money Le but less
risk debt is risk how old are you Martha
I'm 61 okay my God how many more working
years do you have now it's GNA give
another couple more years okay what's
your
income huh what's your income aside from
the rental properties what do you do for
a living and how much do you make we uh
we generate a good 200 right now who's
we my husband and I okay so he's working
as well does he have any assets or is
this what you laid out is that
everything between the both of you
that's everything for us okay so what if
we put this 200 to good work for the
next five years because you know what
200,000 is for five years that means a
million dollars is going to pass through
your fingers over the next five
years now what most people do is they
wake up and go oh my gosh we made 200
Grand we're doing doing our taxes I
don't know where it all went we got
nothing to show for it or you could take
advantage of all these catch-up
contributions start maxing out your
retirement accounts start scking away
money and have some retirement with
dignity that's my goal for you but the
way to do it you've done such a great
job getting these places paid off and
now you're telling me you want to go
back into
debt which is not going to set you up in
retirement what it is I don't see as a
debt I you don't see a mortgage as a
debt no because that's something to I I
they've done some really great marketing
then haven't they it's literally in the
program it's called a reverse mortgage
do you know where the word mortgage
comes from it's a French word death
pledge okay did you know
that it's a real fun dark fact for you
Martha and so if you're telling me
that's not debt when the word death
pledgees in it I don't know what to tell
you you call the wrong show today but I
want you to have an amazing retirement I
want you to travel and I also know that
going into de is going to hinder your
ability to travel and right now we're
getting stared over what a rental income
could do for us and I also know during
Co you couldn't even collect rent it was
a moratorium and it caused a lot of
people to freak out for good reason true
that part is true and so that I don't
want you in a situation like that and
what happens if the HVAC goes or the
renters don't pay or you have trouble
filling that spot it's not a fullof over
in the Amalfi Coast you know what are
you going to do then I would set some
goals over what we're going to do for
the next five years because I don't want
you working in your
70s okay is that fair that's fair okay
and I would not be scared of the stock
market if you are keep listening to this
show connect with one of our smartvestor
Pros they've got a a heart of a teacher
and this is a network of investing
professionals across the country they
don't work for us but they will take
care of you and help guide you along
this investing journey and give you some
peace that your money's not going to
disappear are you you were serious about
the mortgage it's a French word for
death I thought you might have been
messing with her no you can Google this
folks I wonder how you say it Pledge
morgage our team just put it up there
French Mort death wow Gage pledge George
you blew my mind I'm full of fun facts
if you guys ever want to do a trivia
night around mortgages take me with you
I'll be your Huckleberry